y siempre que estoy en un escenario
recuerdo la primera vez porque nuestras
primeras veces nos evocan los procesos
hace 24 años
la primera vez que abre en público me
quedé paralizada a los 5 minutos eso no
tuvo buen fin
tuvieron que bajarme del escenario
cuando llegué a casa llegué muy molesta
y le dije a mi mamá a mí no me gusta
hablar en público yo no regreso jamás no
me vuelvo a parar frente a un escenario
mi madre
patricia lo que a ti no te gusta es
sentirse torpe e incapaz
y si tienes que ir vas
y tú te presentas y haces lo mejor que
puedas esa era mi madre
y sabía un montón de cosas
así que hoy vine y me presenté y sigo
aprendiendo
y el quiero hablarles sobre vivir bajo
presión algunos de los presentes ha
vivido bajo presión
mira según las estadísticas entre 19 y
33 años tenemos más presión levanten la
mano
el 75% de las personas que trabajamos
levanten la mano y también viven bajo
estrés a aquellas personas que la semana
pasada durmieron poco o mal levanten la
mano
todos vivimos bajo presión
todos vivimos bajo este demandante
cotidianidad que nos va exigiendo mucho
y para eso no hay nada mejor que una
historia esta es la historia de un
submarino estadounidense uno nuclear
en abril de 1963 salió a pruebas al
océano atlántico y todo iba muy bien
hasta cuando después de una hora
la tripulación anunció que había
pequeños problemas después vino un
silencio
y después de ese silencio un estruendo
el submarino desapareció del radio y del
radar salieron a la búsqueda y solo
pudieron encontrar algunas manchas de
aceite y algunos elementos que estaban
ahí tirados el submarino había
desaparecido con 129 personas al
interior y no había la suficiente
información para saber qué pasó que
había pasado la hipótesis más cercana
era que la presión había sido superior a
la capacidad interna de soportarla así
que se generó una implosión y todo
aquello explotó
de alguna manera cada uno de nosotros
vivimos bajo esa presión bajo la presión
del dinero
de esas situaciones económicas que a
veces son apremiantes de una enfermedad
de la muerte de alguien que amamos bajo
esa presión de la vida que nos va
exigiendo más y más todos hemos estado
en ese submarino
yo estuve en el mío hace 10 años ha sido
mi mayor presión hace 10 años tuve una
tromboembolia pulmonar masiva y esta
tromboembolia
es cuando muchos globos de tu sangre se
hacen coágulos y en mi caso se me fueron
a la parte superior y de pronto ya no
puedes respirar y sucede un colapso
hubo varias diagnósticos estuve un
tiempo bajo observación y no pudieron
detectar qué es lo que lo había
provocado la hipótesis más cercana es
que lo había provocado la presión
externa que había sido superior a la
capacidad interna
estrés y cansancio emocional
y lo primero que yo pensé fue como pude
hacerme esto a mí
así que ahora la tarea de la era más
sencilla bueno parecía sencilla hay que
bajarle al estrés porque todo mundo me
lo decía no vivas una vida tan estresada
siempre andas de arriba para abajo para
que usas para que llevas tantos
proyectos este no te puedes quedar
quieta menos de 100 desde chiquita
entonces ahora esta tarea que tenía por
frente debía de ser emocionante debía de
ser interesante el vivir una vida plena
una vida este navidad feliz y pues si yo
soy una estresada en recuperación
[Música]
y a eso me he dedicado en los últimos 10
años en vivir esa vida plena en donde
para mí todo era extraño porque yo
siempre fue la hiperactiva de la clase
yo siempre fue fui a la que no podía
poner atención la que siempre estaba muy
estresada entonces ahora las cosas que
me decían para que yo pudiera vivir esta
vida y reducir el nivel de estrés y no
volver a tener un episodio de otro
colapso pues era muy sencilla quizá tú
la has escuchado la primera es las
emociones matan
así que hay que tenerlas a raya
y mi vida era una montaña rusa
cosa difícil
segundo el estrés es el asesino
silencioso hay que mantener lejos y
evitarlo
y yo no sabía funcionar sin estrés de
hecho yo soy de las personas que dicen
que bajo estrés funciona mucho mejor
alguien en la sala bajo estrés funcionó
mejor y la tercera es que las personas
son tóxicas aléjate de ellas y yo
convivía con personas tóxicas 24 horas
al día
porque para que me dieron estrés la
tóxica era yo
[Música]
entonces en esta situación yo me
empezaba a sentir muy incómoda uno de
los momentos más incómodos que yo viví
es cuando me dijeron tienes que poner la
mente en blanco
y yo no sé cómo hacer eso
como poner la mente en blanco tienes que
mantenerte lejos de todo eso y para mí
era demasiado raro porque por ejemplo
cuando me decían que había que estar
lejos de la gente tóxica resultaba algo
muy complejo porque mi mente que es muy
gráfica pensaba en esto es tener me
encanta y me encanta porque no se me
ocurrió a mí y me reír por días no este
cuando sabes cuando los dos saben que
son tóxicos pero tratan de hacerlo lo
mejor
y entonces en este momento era muy muy
complicado porque porque está esta
presión era era demasiada ahora tuve un
segundo episodio después de aquella
trombosis en este caso fue algo leve sin
grandes consecuencias pero entonces la
culpa y la vergüenza fue todavía mayor
que no te quieres lo suficiente no
aprendiste la primera vez porque otra
vez tengo una trombosis y la respuesta
la descubrí muy rápido
ahora estoy estresada por no expresarlo
así que empezó esta búsqueda y este
viaje para descubrirlo porque este
estrés venía de algo que llamó la
industria de la felicidad no porque la
felicidad está bien esté mal sino porque
esta industria nos presiona mucho hemos
idealizado demasiado la idea de estar
bien de ser felices de tener éxito
lo que yo le llamo de ser siempre
felices y perfecto exitosos es una
presión que cuando estamos frente a
ellas nos sentimos torpes e incómodos yo
me empecé a dar cuenta que cuando la
gente estaba muy feliz a mi alrededor me
caía mal
o me parecía a sus pechos y no porque no
le creyera sabes no por eso sino porque
yo no podía con este sentimiento de
porque yo no es lo que me falta para
poder ser así de feliz para poder
recuperarme tan pronto para no ser tan
sensible o también juana qué es lo que
me falta es como cuando estás en la
escuela y entonces están todo está están
explicando algo
pero tú eres la única persona que no
entiende y volteas a ver a los otros
todos están entendiendo nadie va a ser
una pregunta
y esa presión hace que uno se quede
callado porque se siente incómodo uno se
siente torpe
así que está esta industria de la
felicidad no nos va presionando y lo que
es terrible es que hemos llevado a
omitir el proceso que hay entre estar
bien y estar mal y entonces esto lo
vemos en blanco y negro en el lenguaje
vemos como hemos suprimido este proceso
porque si no eres exitoso eres fracasado
porque si no vives la vida con pasión
entonces estás en tu zona de confort
porque si no estás feliz tranquila es
porque te estás amargando hemos obviado
que hay una serie de cosas entre el
negro y el blanco
hay muchos colores pero nos sentimos mal
y nos sentimos culpables y los
experimentamos empezamos desde cuando
somos muy pequeñas y muy pequeños y
cuando uno está llorando nos dicen no
llores
porque te ves fea no te enojes porque
nadie te va a querer vamos omitiendo
este transitar por la vida y poder
experimentarla como es nos presentamos
tratando solamente de llegar al
resultado y esta es una presión terrible
así que en este camino en esta búsqueda
una de las cosas que yo descubrí es que
no hay fórmulas que la fórmula para ser
feliz y para estar bien no es de una
sola manera porque donde todos están
pensando nadie piensa lo mismo donde
todas las personas queremos lo mismo
es que no se asoma la libertad
así que
y descubrir tres cosas que es algo de lo
que quiero poner en esta conversación la
primera de ellas es que las emociones no
son malas las emociones son necesarias
porque son el filtro en el cual tú y yo
lidiamos con la vida en el que nos
relacionamos con el otro en que
aprendemos en el que generamos empatía a
través de sentir el dolor en el que nos
enojamos por las cosas que no son justas
que no son correctas y por eso podemos
levantar la voz en el que a veces nos
cansamos y tiramos la toalla y está bien
el estrés no es un asesino silencioso
porque el estrés es algo que está
presente en todos los seres vivos no
podemos evitarlo y evitar es la
principal causa de estrés
así lo demuestran algunas
investigaciones por ejemplo cuando una
persona considera que vive una vida con
estrés su riesgo de tener un colapso o
de morir por causas asociadas
relacionadas al estrés es del 43% pero
este porcentaje se va a cero
si la persona considera que vive bajo
estrés pero no considera que el estrés
es negativo
es decir ahí no tengo riesgo el riesgo
está cuando yo lo pienso la autora que
el imacon igal nos dice que cuando yo
considero que el estrés es algo útil en
mi vida porque lo es eso genera la
biología del coraje de la valentía de
asumir el riesgo y otro dato cuando una
persona está viviendo una situación
estresante ese riesgo de tener un
colapso es del 30% pero si esa persona
lo vive en compañía de otros de otras
ayuda y pide ayuda ese 30% de riesgo
desaparece
el estrés no es el enemigo
es como el caso de una gacela cuando una
gacela de que hay un león entonces va a
vivir estrés porque el estrés nos hace
sobrevivir nos hace enfrentar la
realidad iban a suceder todas estas
cosas va a bach se van a vaciar de
glucosa el hígado va a aumentar la
glucemia va a haber ácidos grasos
en nuestra sangre de ahí las
enfermedades que seguramente hemos
escuchado asociadas al estrés se acelera
el corazón y la respiración
entonces la gacela huye y se salva
ahora tenemos el caso de juan
y juan está padeciendo estrés quizás por
su jefe quizá por la esposa por la
suegra por alguna razón y cuando juan se
estresa le pasa muy similar a lo que le
sucede a la gacela se vacía la glucosa
del hígado hay una glucemia aumentan los
ácidos grasos no se acelera la
respiración la diferencia es que juan no
corre
no desahogar las emociones no es ahoga
esa carga
y este es lo que hace necesario que
podamos tener ese trabajo de autocuidado
y dejar de pensar que el estrés es malo
y finalmente las personas no son tóxicos
tóxico es el plástico
tóxico es el cloro si te lo tomas
tóxicas la contaminación pero las
personas no son tóxicas y no estoy
diciendo que no nos alejemos de aquellas
personas que ponen en riesgo nuestra
vida en cualquier área en cualquier
dimensión sino que hemos llegado a este
simplismo de o es blanco o es negro no
quiero estar feliz ni enojado quiero
estar no quiero estar triste ni anja
quiero estar siempre feliz que entonces
a todas aquellas personas que no piensan
como yo
que me contradicen a todas esas personas
las voy a alejar en aras de decir que es
tóxica qué pasaría si mejor elevamos
nuestras habilidades de comunicación y
de comprensión hacia el otro porque la
propuesta no es que hay una sola forma
de ser feliz sino que la vida nos
presentamos ante ella con lo mejor que
somos y lo mejor que somos es el proceso
que hemos vivido mi camino fue muy largo
hubiera querido que ahí estuviera mi
madre para decírmelo
seguramente me hubiera cortado la
distancia pero la gente que amamos muere
siempre prematuramente siempre
pero si algo me hubiera podido decir
esto preséntate preséntate en la vida
experimental ya irás aprendiendo nos
conocemos a partir de mostrarnos
vulnerables a partir de los errores a
partir de no poder más porque a veces
somos esa persona que nos a pachorra mos
que tiramos la toalla que vamos
arrastrando la cobija y está bien porque
es ahí donde nos vinculamos y el riesgo
el riesgo es caer en el narcisismo y en
la empatía cero o dicho de otra forma en
la indiferencia y en la dolencia
presentarnos siempre frente a la vida
aunque nos sintamos torpes aunque nos
sintamos incapaces
es vivir precisamente es poder tener la
capacidad de vivir la vida en blanco y
negro sin en toda la gama de colores
no se le puede decir a una persona que
ha desaparecido su hijo o su hija
todo pasa por algo no se le puede decir
a un hombre échale ganas cuando ha
perdido todo no le podemos decir a una
persona
que le arrancaba a alguien la violencia
a un familiar todo va a estar bien
porque quizás no está bien evitar ese
simplismo es poder conectar con nosotros
el día más feliz de mi vida fue el día
que empecé a trabajar en cárceles este
es un mural que está en una cárcel
penitenciaria en islas marías
yo no sé cómo enseñar a ser feliz
pero lo que hago en mi trabajo es
enseñar a crear una red de seguridad
ahí aprendí esta frase las dulces no
saben si las amargas así que celebremos
las dulces pero acompañemos no siempre
en las amargas
[Aplausos]
[Música]